hello and welcome to this video playing
the big master bik minus master okay so
the good word lon lon system let's see
yeah it's not one of those openings that
really makes you pop the champagne
bottles when your face it with black
what not much to do you have to just
live with those systems and yeah try to
grind people down from those equal
positions so here I've traded some time
in for the pair of bishops yeah and it's
got the slightly weakened pawn structure
it's not a big deal actually the points
but it's something that does not go away
all that quickly and yeah might might be
something that you do can do something
with in the long run so yeah I can give
him another double porn sure it doesn't
doesn't feel great idea to give up this
Bishop and I'd be five you might play
that then I could be tempted to take it
actually huh oh
huh interesting and now taking it and
playing like h5 and g6 yes h4 can be
might be an issue for him okay I don't
have to do it right away
just anticipating 95
it's not I don't want to prevent
anything going to be five that's not a
threat but I want to make the night
movable that it can go to before or some
other square nine eight seven and
possibly Bishop b5 is also an idea
ok now I'm going for this and try to
play 9 a-7 Bishop b5 the night ending
would be quite ok here because his pawn
structure is somewhat weak a knight
coming to a 5 for example would be
excellent when the bishops are traded
and the night cannot be taken on f5 so
like night a 7 Bishop b5 trade this 95
96 95 this is a an idea form for black
to do something you might might be quick
there on the on the C file
[Music]
look see one I can also play rook c8
first if I do this with Bishop b5 it's
not clear that he has to take it of
course I can just take and can just go
back as well ok now you can always go
back which is pretty important
I might still have gained us a little
something there because i have probably
be six we takes it wow I this isn't this
is an ending that I'm feel fairly
comfortable with maybe I cannot win let
that's absolutely possible of it it
looks it looks comfortable if I go to f6
and then night f5
and we're here you put them on dark
squares here be 698 is winning the pawn
and b6 next be 5v5 I feel as
questionable this is just a pawn visual
a 6cm ok good trick a good trick good
trick
you
[Music]
I should do this actually win the porn
like that just approach with the King
some things yeah and now nights you
phone takes thanks King there it's not
clear but but but but with which if I go
Knight a5 here 94 take taking before
King v6 can see for I'm not sure that
this wins not sure that this wins time
morning
you
this one check this should be eight can
u 7s Bishop c6 again disk this stuff and
here maybe this isn't actually winning
which is pretty awkward but wait how is
he wait wait wait wait this is strapped
this is a trap piece how do i get to the
pawns there with the night I don't have
to write I just have to march the edge
pawn check check check white forfeits on
time ok yeah some some scammers yeah I
was extremely surprised that he traded
all the rooks because that that can only
be problematic for for him also I did
that I don't believe it I don't think I
should win or something but it feels
like this is tricky night FYI this is
always tough too tough too tough to tell
just a second just ask me what I think
yeah the here may 94 seems to be
according to the engine but it's
something that I couldn't couldn't
calculate probably guy he's got too many
weaknesses and not so many reserve moves
I have a couple of reserve moves f6f 5
and so on this still ose five the issue
like a five and at the end g5 possible
and now whether it is a drug don't
understand the engineer by the way what
is it what's happening a king c7 or
tortoises what is the winning idea here
probably five yeah that that should be
the winning idea here like go here and
then some some e five maybe let's say I
just just tried something I don't really
think about the engine now at the end
register and now this oh no he king c4
course so be 35 that could be a winning
idea and now just go here something like
that yeah so nice yeah it sit here and
think this is seems questionable to me
b5 the computer just wants to take maybe
[Music]
write a five looks extremely natural and
this should probably Lucy I'd it does
and if you just stay is like like this I
go b6 and this this is probably a draw I
have two way forward this is probably a
drawing in here I think I should win
this is a funny move I had to repeat
them and now yeah and now the thing is I
think this probably does win and the
engine gives us as well yeah I wasn't so
sure I wasn't sure if I'm winning here
like this this this and now he goes with
his own stuff here I can I can play this
but I'm not making any progress and this
is strong I cannot I cannot force any
concession it just plays m3 and here
widest even winning I don't actually see
why but
25 I just goes there okay yeah I'm smart
okay that doesn't work but this is
winning at it does win age for Hanks
check and this is ultimately leaving the
bishop trapped yeah interesting an
interesting ending in those London
systems you have to be persistent and
play for small things sometimes yeah
things materialize okay thanks for
watching